javie GPM hi Charlie young city iantine
de hungry yo machine cola whatever
tamron young oh yeah her too young to me
fabio chang no kizuna me Shanna maybe
our search engine overhaul here yes
Julia sheer get a travel in it amazing
zai chi gong xiang voila panget oye sun
kazamia amisa punzo chinda nation amah
danger zones OG para lo merecen viajero
raja muda sinned and ah yes a silly
omega lambda chi gong home bazooka she
will emboss fushia hey lucha hey she she
turned out on fuji third on de
chevaliers you don't share it on the
former we can talk in here let us
continue this discussion either the
generator of the boys world capitalist
equation so that delightful tidings of
our socialist triumph may boys for their
cult imperialist hearts as a bamboo
spear so a ball of gypsum tell us of the
vast improvements to our space explorers
or where a very pleasant living
conditions that living room looks very
comfortable affirmative come back then
they secretary far more comfortable and
spacious
and my home on earth and I thought well
miss my wife at all thanks to the
company of my very experienced comrade
but they call here in chinese launch
style is both romantic and timelessly
elegant unfortunately the outhouse isn't
heated yes but they're more memories of
the emotional climax of the six plenary
session of the 18th Central Committee
keep our hearts and digestive tract at
operating temperature my poo poo is now
floating in space I've personally
thought that the recession want the best
of the whole season and I count the days
till the next season when yeah I got the
cliffhanger at the end of the episode
and I'm anxious to see if you ain't up
together with don't earring Oh shadow
nearly as exciting as twice where are
all huge fans of people's republic
excellent state babacan Daniels car till
when you're on Bo all the way well
captain kirk and mr. Spock let me say it
again and I'll also speak for many taxi
Doumit members of the CPC Central
Committee and the entire Chinese
modeling form Tibbett to the South China
Sea well I says it we are part of your
effort to seek out new lives and
civilizations and to boldly go where no
man has gone before Thank You comrade
general secretary I like you new iphone
as soon as we have completed our mission
and delivered by order of Peking duck
with hot and also to moon base over we
shall probably return towards the length
of the Rising Sun at the setting press
freedom I'm looking for my thoughts even
200 I Met Your father I am fully
convinced that we will never see you
alive again but we will do our best to
preserve your memories as socialist
heroes for as long as we deem necessary
can I say hello to all my Facebook
friends over hang out right time now for
lunch have your quick executions and
down to the respected massage parlor
happy ending it's a freakin wicked baby
and I'm about to have some miss some fun
you
[Music]